[Music]
fresh from their Oscar victory last week
film director bong joon-ho and cast
members of parasites helped their first
news conference back home in Seoul but
some concealer didn't there I feel happy
that it's now come to an end my happy
end I worked very hard I was thinking
about taking a break
Daisy told me not to rest it's been a
long road to success for BOM who was
once on a government blacklist created
during former President Lee myung-bak
rule from 2008 and expanded under his
successor Park geun-hye the list was
intended to cut off state funding to
artists deemed too critical of the
administration parts involvement in that
led in part to demonstrations against
her and her eventual downfall in the
past decade South Korean Entertainment
has made waves abroad it's pop music
known as kpop has become a global
phenomenon while Korean dramas have
gained a loyal following in Asia to the
Wando yumpire film cornices believe
parasite could herald a new era for
Korean films many of them are audiences
who saw Korean film for the first time
in their lives this number of audiences
will be potential Korean film market and
I was also told that there's so many us
facing distributors who just began to
seek out distributing more Korean films
into u.s. parasites theme of income
inequality resonates with its audience
but ironically the film was only made
possible with backing from CJ groups a
family controlled conglomerate these
companies known as chaebol controlled
much of South Korea's economy and are
often seen as perpetuating the wealth
gap the success of parasite has now cast
a spotlight on chaebols role in the
movie industry many such firms own
Cineplex --is and film studios and have
been accused of investing mostly in
formulaic blockbusters rather than films
that promote creativity and diversity I
made my debut in 1999
the Korean movie industry has been a
splendid development over the past 20
years however at the same time it has
become more difficult for young
directors to make using unique and
adventurous attempts young talented
directors rather than being absorbed
into the movie industry now make
independent movies a film critic says
South Korea's movie industry is at a
pivotal moment I think it's up those two
studios to maybe take more take risks
with younger filmmakers and try and
finance you know independent films and
encourage and ensure that these younger
directors have opportunities many are
hoping that parasite will lead the way
to a bolder path for South Korea's film
industry
Florence lui Al Jazeera's